hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcasting
just checking in on you
who
oh my god what a whirlwind [ __ ] week
since i last talked to you
on monday
um i've gone to new york
done the patrice o'neal benefit and come
back
through the magic of aviation
um
it was great man
[ __ ] show was amazing
um all of these comics that came on
everybody [ __ ] killed and
then
the surprise of the night dave attell
shows up
um
as a surprise guest walks on and just
absolutely [ __ ] destroyed
um hilarious he's out there with his
winter jacket on and his all this
[ __ ]
winter hat the whole thing looking crazy
and uh
just such a big heart a guy everybody
killed salvo cano killed [ __ ] pete
davidson killed rich voss as always
as always
uh yamaneika saunders matteo lane
mike vaccione did i get everybody i know
i always miss somebody
who was in there i jumped around the
order
ah [ __ ] i know i forgot somebody
oh mike distefano
christos stefano
i [ __ ] said that
i said to him dude i kept calling you
christie stefano because of mike
uh
now i'm forgetting all it's either de
stefano
adista mike d stefano and chris
destefano
and i finally said his last name right
and then i called him mike
chris de stefano
there i finally said it right [ __ ]
murdered
great energy crowd loved him and um
and i'm [ __ ] mopped up in the end
there wasn't a lot left
everybody had killed so hard we had just
such a [ __ ] great time it was david
tell's birthday we got to sing happy
birthday to him sherrod small
forgot about him
uh he [ __ ] killed it
my old buddy from back in the day was
down in the comedy cellar when it was
yeah i remember when it was just one rum
i remember the comedy seller before the
comedy seller got famous
i'll tell you something kids
that people used to have to stand out in
front and bark i tell you to get people
to go in there
um
and i'll tell you i got a couple of
[ __ ] crazy goddamn stories
that you know if we didn't live in such
a [ __ ] douchey goddamn time where
everybody's trying to get everybody in
trouble the [ __ ] [ __ ] that i saw down
there before cellphone cameras
the [ __ ] that i saw
it just was [ __ ] amazing
it was [ __ ] amazing you know
it was
it was [ __ ] unbelievable
and uh
you missed it
you missed it you know what if you ever
see me
i don't i can't trust you guys someone
will rap me out i'd tell you one of the
[ __ ] stories i actually told it um
this past week to some comics when we
got together we were remembering uh bob
saget and everything so we were going
around telling our crazy stories so i
[ __ ] brought this one up let's just
say
yeah let's just leave it that anyway um
so i came back to new york and uh you
know what's great on the way out and the
way back
i was on a [ __ ] wide-body airplane
and those are the ones that i remember
when i was a kid
you know you came in and there was there
was two aisles that you could go down
and there was these [ __ ] ron burgundy
colors all over the plane they were like
[ __ ]
orange seats
which is everything was [ __ ] vivid
in the 70s i don't know what it was that
[ __ ] orange the blues everything just
jumped out at you
and it looked classy now it looks tacky
as hell but anyway it reminded me back
the day you know you get on eastern
airlines
the one time we did that we got on
eastern airlines and went down to
[ __ ] uh disney world
when they were building the epcot center
that's how [ __ ] old i am the epcot
center was not
open
that stupid ball thing or whatever i
don't think i've ever been there
no
i only i went to disney world
once
when i was a kid i went this in like 82
or 83.
how the [ __ ] old was that it was a lo
you know what i know i know what
it was the year tron came out
because they're doing that stupid parade
going down main street
um and then they had a float where all
the actors were acting they would it was
like if you turn tron into a musical
um tron
original here we
go i remember they were singing this
it was just like this [ __ ] dance
music
1982. yeah we went in the summer of 82.
so they were promoting the movie
and everybody was dressed like in blue
and they had this really bad like 80s
sort of casio
space laser sound and when they did it
the dancers would like point at the
crowd like they were shooting a laser at
you and i was looking at it i was like
wow this is kind of weird
um and at one point i looked up at my
mother and she made this weird face and
she pointed at me like exaggerating then
i laughed to myself going
okay this is stupid
it has been confirmed by my mother that
what in f in fact what i am watching is
[ __ ] stupid
um
so anyway uh
jesus christ it's funny the amount of
times i've come back down to florida
there's just there's no [ __ ] way you
know what as a comedian what am i gonna
go to disney disney [ __ ] world by
myself
jesus christ
[ __ ] bald red [ __ ] red bearded
creep walking around
oh i know what it was i went to
disneyland out here
that's what it was that's why i thought
i came back
i did that with my wife
and then i remember one time she went
for somebody's birthday and they wanted
to be there all day because they like
loved
disneyland
and i remember my wife when she came
home was just like i don't ever want to
go to that [ __ ] place again
and we have not
i have honored her wish
um
i mean we're gonna go when the kids get
a little bit older
you know
as covet is starting to die out it seems
hopefully i don't know
i don't know
is it just the new normal
who knows so anyway the [ __ ] wide
bodies that's what i'm talking about
i gotta bring those [ __ ] things back
let's turn up the heat on this global
warming it's what i say bigger jets more
fuel
let's just end this whole thing all of
us just yelling at each other
on the internet
i think that's how it ends everybody
thought it was gonna be a meteor
people thought jesus was gonna come back
somebody said something about bigfoot i
don't think it's gonna be any of those
things
i think we're all just gonna [ __ ] be
so
sucked into yelling at each other we're
gonna forget to eat
no that would never happen
i don't know what it is you know what
here's something for you here's
something you never hear on the internet
guess what everybody i don't know what
i'm talking about
i don't have the answers
i'm going to be the anti-internet guy
i'd love to hear your opinion
i have no idea what i'm to i am not
qualified
to speak on the end of the world how
about that
i can give you a theory but i'm just
letting you know that i'm pulling it
directly out of my freckled ass
isn't that refreshing i bet you could
run for president on that
uh candidate burr what would you do to
uh try to fix the economy i have no
clue i almost cursed but that would have
been the end of my campaign i i have no
idea
i'll be honest with you i don't
understand how it works
you know
i don't understand why
bitcoin that ponzi scheme is a better
ponzi scheme than the american dollar
i don't understand why if there's no
gold behind our money why it [ __ ]
matters as long as everybody agrees that
paper is worth something because it's
really hard to counterfeit
why can't we just do that i don't
understand why
if we just print enough to pay off the
trail we'll just print a trillion
dollars and start paying people
what is the [ __ ] problem
then everybody around the world can go
buy a ferrari
then everybody has a ferrari
you know what
everybody gets a ferrari and then people
would be [ __ ] annoyed because
everyone has a ferrari and then they
wouldn't feel special so then they'd
have to go out and they'd have to put
some friday flare on it
on that piece of art they put some
[ __ ] cheesy wrap on it
you know
just so you stick out you think that
that makes you different
that you're carrying the torch of punk
rock
um
yeah
i have no idea how the world's gonna end
the same way i had no idea who was gonna
win the football games i think i lost
every [ __ ] bet except to the rams
game what a bunch of boring ass [ __ ]
games that was we'll be talking about it
later with versey jesus christ
my god every game was over by the
[ __ ] second quarter
um except the cowboys and um
cowboys and uh 49ers was you know got
exciting later i guess
jesus christ
one of those guys gonna wake up
you know
it's funny
you know what i don't understand about
texas you can't get an abortion there
anymore but jerry jones can still run
the cowboys
somebody explained that one to me jesus
christ
at what point are you guys going to
realize it was jimmy johnson
jimmy
oh jimmy
i would be trolling him with that i
would just be sending him
you know a picture of jimmy johnson with
that [ __ ] audio from ray leota and
he's in in the shower
when they do the liftwanza heist or
whatever he's like oh
jimmy
[Music]
i don't get it man
i don't get it
i don't understand like you gotta the
cowboys have not won
or even been to the super bowl in 27
[ __ ] years and how i always do that
how i put things into perspective
because as you get older 27 years feels
like seven years
so what i just do i always go back to
like 1990 and i subtract the number
so 1990 minus 27
is 1963 then i'm like holy [ __ ] that is
a long [ __ ] time because if you said
they haven't been there since 1995 i'm
like yeah you know it
was a little while ago
it wasn't a long while ago a little
holy [ __ ] i was 27 in 1995.
that was half
my life ago for the first half of my
life
the cowboys were that was that was the
thing
they got to turn that around man jesus
christ
i mean what else do they have in dallas
they just got a bunch of stuff that's
big but like
nothing to hang your hat on right
literally
i actually really like dallas i like
dallas and i like houston
i used to hate houston because it was
just hot as [ __ ] balls
you know what i mean
and then austin i liked because of
stevie ray vaughan and then i went there
and saw all these dirty sweaty white
kids and i just was like
yeah
you know
[Music]
it had that patchouli vibe i'm sure it
doesn't
but that's i don't know
i know i always get nervous when a town
says keep it weird
i'm like oh no
are these nerdy white people that think
they're cool bill why do you have to
[ __ ] on cities that you know you want to
go to and sell tickets and i don't know
i'm just killing time i like austin i go
down i look at the bats i go down to the
stevie ray vaughn statue
i do that [ __ ] right
you know what it is i like the texas
longhorns
i just don't like the [ __ ] traffic
[ __ ] two-lane goddamn highway going
in there
[ __ ] nine million [ __ ] people out
there
that's got bad traffic atlanta
horrific traffic
new york city obviously
boston
boston oh my god they did spend all that
money on the big dig and they didn't
even add any [ __ ] lanes
didn't even add any [ __ ]
lanes
like the amount of money that was
skimmed off that project just has to be
uh
out of this [ __ ] world like how
greedy are you that you [ __ ] people that
bad
you [ __ ] them over that god damn bad
knowing the population is increasing and
you're just in the moment going i don't
give a [ __ ]
that fourth lane
i don't even understand the big dig to
be honest with you half the time it's
just two lanes and then there's a giant
emergency lane that nobody can use and
you're just sitting there and [ __ ]
bumper to bumper traffic
but massachusetts was always weird with
that [ __ ]
do you know what's an amazing thing that
in massachusetts i don't know if they
still have it every other city as you
approach the exit the sign comes first
and there's an arrow
like exit 4a you drive past the sign and
then you know
that's your exit
boston put the sign like on the exit
like it's right there as you're driving
by going 60 miles an hour probably
doesn't matter anymore because
everybody's got the gps things over
there
right everybody's got that stuff going
on um
so anyway
um
i am back out here
and uh
i don't know what i'm doing man i'm just
[ __ ] trying to
shake off that goddamn heartburn i just
couldn't lay off i'm usually i try to be
good when i go to new york and then last
night after the benefit you know
we didn't end up getting uh there was no
after party because of all the covid
[ __ ] regulations and all that [ __ ]
so we ended up uh
i don't know we just [ __ ] drove back
to my hotel and there was a deli across
the street i was just like
i gotta get a bacon egg and cheese right
i gotta do that so
i went down i got a [ __ ] bacon egg
and cheese
i don't know
woke up again with heartburn i'm like
what am i doing
what the [ __ ] am i doing so
it's weird
i don't think cause i don't party
anymore it's just kind of all about the
food now i got to do something right
you [ __ ] alone in your s in a city
you're not drinking you're not drugging
the [ __ ] else am i gonna do
get myself a sandwich there
um
so
anyway i got a couple of reads i got to
do here
um
the [ __ ] are they
where is it oh there we go
oh look who it is oh my god one of my
favorite people of all time it's all zip
[Music]
you know if you work for if you work for
or own a business in one of these
growing industries or a wide range of
other industries you probably need to
hire
asap what the [ __ ] was that sentence if
you work for for or own a business sorry
in one of these growing industries what
growing industries i don't know
or a wide range
of other industries
you probably need to hire asap all right
so evidently whatever you're in
is growing exponentially uh there's only
one place to go you got to go to zip
and right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
zip
uses powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates up with your
job then it proactively presents these
candidates to you
you can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply to your job which encourages
them to apply faster no wonder zip
recruit is the number one rated hiring
site in the united states based on g2
ratings
uh zip
technology jeff recruiters technology is
so effective that four to five employees
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day
um and for and
now you can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
that's ziprecruiter.com
b-u-r-r once again zip
the smartest way to hire all right oh
look who it is people it's helix or is
it helix
we're gonna say helix helix sleep sleep
is important
hot take everybody sleep is important
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattresses
for you mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress pad for someone else with
helix you're getting a mattress that you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody's unique and helix knows
that helis knows that you don't got to
tell them that [ __ ] so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
down
uh cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains and
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers just go to
helixsleep.com take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix even
has financing options and flexible
payment plans to get a great night's
sleep so a great night's sleep is never
far away helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helix sleep.com
for up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows all right look who it is
everybody it's all birds
all birds a-l-l
birds
um even though it will be wet and chilly
in most parts of the country
running will still be part of people's
lives trying to achieve their personal
best how about a shout out for people
that run in the sleet i mean that's a
that's dedication uh the wool dasher
mizzle
our weather repellent performance
running shoe is the first shoe of its
kind it's sustainably made from natural
materials with a low environmental
impact on the planet
but you've got goals to meet in miles to
log keep your feet warm and dry with the
weather repellent wool dasher mizzle
shoe from all birds
all birds printed the wool dasher
missile carbon footprint right on the
shoe so you know it's impact on the
planet
how about a shout out to all birds that
they actually know how to how i know how
to read a carbon footprint chart uh then
they offset that footprint to zero to
make it a carbon neutral product all
birds built the wood dasher muzzle using
natural materials to have a low
environmental impact so you can break a
sweat without breaking the planet
uh
sorry i'll just talk about sleep with
helix i'm falling asleep here this
winter keep your feet cozy and dry with
the all birds wood wool dasher mizzles
discover your perfect pair at
allbirds.com that's a-l-l-b-r-d-s
dot-com um
oh i gotta tell you some [ __ ] that made
me feel [ __ ]
really [ __ ] old as [ __ ]
so i'm in new york
and um
what did i forget i forgot what i was
packing and i just forgot something i
was like you got to be [ __ ] me so i
went out to go buy some goddamn thermals
right you know the [ __ ] waffle stitch
thing right
so i'm like i know i'll just go over to
the foot locker they always have them
there right go over to foot locker i
didn't get to foot locker i saw another
workout place
then all this warm [ __ ] for jogging and
all this stuff so i came in i said
hey you sell any thermals here
and this kid's looking at me like
doesn't really know what i'm talking
about i'm like you know like the the
classic dermals you mean he was like you
mean like the waffle print
yeah
waffle stitched to whatever they said
they said yeah they and
he's like no we don't we don't sell
those everything that these people sell
nowadays with that [ __ ] they talk about
wicking moisture away from your body
so i'm like all right so i go alright
that's cool no worries i'll go over to
the foot locker and he's like i don't
think they're gonna have them there
so i was like all right so i just looked
up
and said they'd have them down at macy's
or they'd have them over at this
nordstroms it's like all right i'll go
to the [ __ ] nordstroms
so i go i go down to the nordstroms
and uh
i come walking in there
and i say to the guy you got some
thermals he's like this is the woman's
place
you know you got to go across the street
so i'm like all right so i go across the
street and i'm like yeah hey you got a i
walk in and they got [ __ ] they got
cookies
in the clothing store like
this place milk that's out here in la
they make cookies for some reason they
have a little station there
i don't know why you'd go in to buy a
shirt and you want [ __ ] cookies it
made no sense to me right so i go
downstairs
and i'm talking to this dude who's
dressed like a woman and has a beard
and a mascot and i'm describing him what
a thermal is i never felt so old in my
[ __ ] life he's looking at me like i
got three [ __ ] heads right
and
he goes uh
he goes me like long johns and by the
way they all talk like this i'm not i'm
not saying everybody i talk to talk like
that you mean like long john's
like jesus christ i don't want like a
[ __ ] trap door to take a [ __ ] in an
outhouse i just want like a thermal he's
like yeah we don't have those
and i wanted to be like yeah what your
[ __ ] website said you did
i swear to god if i was a [ __ ]
dictator and you google something
and this [ __ ] store
says that they have it and they show up
and you they don't [ __ ] have it
because they think that you're just
gonna go in there
and just resign yourself to buy
something there
because their [ __ ] website nerd
just just sucked me in with whatever my
shirt my shirt search was
so i'm you know
i'm [ __ ] pissed
it's like i don't give a [ __ ] about you
you're wicking away moisture horse [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] walking so i gotta walk out
of there and all of a sudden the cookie
made it made sense to me
like at least i can get something here
i'll get a cookie i like those cookies
they haven't milk i'm gonna get one of
these things so i go over
and i'm looking at the uh
the cookie names i'm so [ __ ] old i
don't recognize any of the flavor they
didn't have a peanut butter cookie they
didn't have a chocolate chip cookie they
didn't know that [ __ ]
so i say the lady behind the counter i
go uh
i want to get cookie i don't recognize
any of these uh go which one's the most
popular i go i know it's not the gluten
one she goes no that one tastes like ass
and
i go all right which one's the most
popular she pointed at one i go okay
what's in that one she goes it's like
crunched up pretzels and potato chips
and i said i forget it forget
it thank you and i just i left
all right
i just
it's like i get it i get it i didn't get
the first 20 times when i was asking for
a [ __ ] thermal that everybody wore up
until i don't know what year
and now
nobody has worn one so for so [ __ ]
long that i went to three different
[ __ ] department stores and i had to
describe it
for a full 15 [ __ ] seconds
before people even remotely knew what i
was talking about as if i didn't feel
that [ __ ] old now i don't even
recognize the name
there's another dictator thing
okay
no salt in desserts
i don't understand that
like if i want salt i'll eat chips if i
want a sugar rush i'll eat something
sugary and i just they like level each
other out
and i just don't feel a rush it's like
i'm going up i'm coming back down
here we go here we got it
so
i don't know
can an old bald orange man just get a
[ __ ] thermal
i bet macy's had him
i just didn't want to go in there they
got like [ __ ] 9
000 [ __ ] floors
you know
and as you go up in that place have you
ever been in that macy's the one where
bullwinkle and all those guys go by on
thanksgiving right santa claus and all
them macy day parade
you go up the escalator and the
escalators they just keep getting
skinnier and skinnier and older and
older
it gets like claustrophobic
you know
i wonder if the top floors are for
people with like eating disorders
they keep all like the ultra
my goal
what is my dieting goal my dieting goal
is that i can shop at the top floor
of the macy's
on 34th street herald square
i'm going to somehow get my hips between
that last
that last escalator on the way up
which is really just like a zip line
at that point if you're like bulimic
they just hang you over like a [ __ ]
shirt drawing and you send you up oh
jesus bill
sorry um
i swear to god if i can't lose this
[ __ ] weight i'm gonna start trying it
i'm gonna start puking
you know i never understood chewing and
spitting
like the discipline of that
it's like right there i get chewing and
then puking it up afterwards
you know
the [ __ ] am i i gotta start having
guests on this [ __ ] i don't even know
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about anymore
um speaking of that speaking of guests
um
now comes the uh the bet mg uh
bet mgm
is that what the [ __ ] it is
sorry people i had a long day the bet
mgm
uh segment
with paul verzi
the winner
of the
2021 jimmy the greek award he beat me by
a half a game
uh we pick four games a week betting
against the spread we bet over 70 games
and both of us were over 500 against the
spread it's pretty goddamn good but this
weekend
you'll hear we got our asses
uh on the playoffs t's and teams i hate
you know teasing teams i don't know it
always seems so [ __ ] easy and then
you get your dick knocked in the dirt so
enjoy this clip right now me and paul
versi
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast a bet mgm
version nfl preview week we are talking
about the
wild card weekend we're going to get
into the divisional playoffs but first
guys as you all know we've teamed up
with bet mgm all year we've absolutely
had a blast uh we'll be using all of bet
mgm's lines the most reliable lines
there are
make all your picks and we'll have
special offers for our listeners each
week we've got exciting news bet mgm is
live in new york guys finally
new york uh you know we don't you don't
have to drive over state lines anymore
to place your bet all right if you're
you're in new york or any other state
where bet mgm is live you haven't signed
up use bonus code bur you'll get two 200
free after placing your first ten dollar
bet here's how it works download the bet
mgm app sign up using bonus code bur
b-u-r-r
place your first ten dollar money line
bet on any nfl game you'll receive two
hundred 200
in free bets immediately after placing
your bet regardless of the outcome i'm
gonna repeat that regardless of the
outcome
okay yes don't uh
so just make sure you use bonus code bur
uh to sign up visit uh bet mgm for terms
and conditions
all right guys so here's the deal man it
was a oh first real quick just because a
lot of people were asking we [ __ ] up
with the jimmy the greek and i was a
game and a half ahead instead of a half
of a game we both finished above 500
though bill going 37 34-1 i went 38-34
we beat the book by seven and a half
games it is two jimmy the greeks now for
bill one for me and uh we're coming back
next year with some fun surprises for
you all so sorry for any confusion as
far as you got the monkey off your back
yeah but you still got the lead dude
you still got the lead you know it's the
best it's the best of seven first to
four gets the trophy
no uh we're gonna do something like that
though but um you wanted a new trophy
every year am i gonna get a bunch of
those [ __ ] things laying around just
keep passing it back and forth i told
bill i said we're gonna send you two
trophies me one trophy and they'll
always be in back of us and bill goes he
nixed it he goes i'm not [ __ ] i don't
want 10 of those to get [ __ ] years
down the line a bunch of [ __ ] laying
around on my got too much stuff man um
wild card weekend was lackluster to say
the i'm not going to lie to you i went
into wildcard weekend talking [ __ ]
saying this is the best weekend of the
football season one of the dark horses
is coming this is gonna be dude i was
[ __ ] almost sleeping in every third
quarter 35 to seven every game was over
and first of all we have to admit paul
we got our [ __ ] asses kicked and i
blame you we did well you know what i'll
tell you why i'm gonna blame you one you
talked all this [ __ ] about how he was
spanking the book yeah and then i asked
you are you gonna weigh in anywhere
and you just you just sat there like a
battered wife and you let me pick
everything and i drove us right off the
[ __ ] cliff no you know what you were
right about something i was wrong you
said the niners getting nine and i said
let's take the cowboys i gotta see that
there's no way they're gonna exit the
first round again give the cowboys three
at home you were a hundred percent right
listen we beat the [ __ ] out of the book
we took a little bit of a we took a
little bit of a bath we what listen it's
a new bit of a bath dude that was
[ __ ] joe pesci in that cornfield
ah he's still breathing he's still
pretty
um we got destroyed the only is the
patriots let's let's let's go through
the bloodbath we tease the patriots we
tease the [ __ ] eagles
both of those things i don't give a [ __ ]
how many points yeah so bill was saying
the the eagles bloodbath what about the
bloodbath that was the steelers the
bloodbath that was the the the
cardinals
dude joe burrow in the joe burrow versus
las vegas was the only game that at
least it was six points down to the end
brutal oh
49 cowboys got a little exciting towards
the end how about the rams i like the
rams just not getting any respect their
defense is [ __ ] good you called that
dude the power rankings they got them
last i don't know man
i like that if they're getting points
this week i like that they got the best
defensive player
in the nfl that aaron donald kid like
you said bill that front four is on a
mission nobody's talking about him
matthew stafford finally has a decent
you know finally
i felt dude that kid was awesome they
were like yeah you never won a playoff
game in 12 seasons you've been to three
year old for three and he didn't [ __ ]
throw detroit under the bus he didn't
say anything he's just like yeah you
know well you know it's another year
i like that
hey
uh
who does tampa bay have this week and
who does green bay have
tampa bay is playing the rams in tampa
brain
oh and who's playing uh
who's green bay has who well i'll tell
you right now we'll go over all the
games right now all right oh cause you
know i'm on my phone because i'm [ __ ]
dealing with situation here well i'll
tell you one thing paulie's uh paulie's
betting this week that much i can tell
you
all right here we go
i'm putting my money where my mouth is
this week bill okay i'm pissed off that
i did that last week i talked a little
[ __ ] but don't worry as you know i'm
bouncing back here here we go this week
we have here are the games and then
we'll break them down we got the
cincinnati bengals
going into a uh tennessee titles bangles
bangles is a girl group the best we're
going to be we're going to be doing this
for years no you were doing good for a
while cincinnati bengals
um at the tennessee titans we got the
san francisco 49 oh that's minus minus
three and a half for tennessee
san francisco 49ers going into lambeau
field packers are minus five and a half
we got the rams going into tampa bay
tampa bay is minus three
and we have the buffalo bills going into
kansas city
kansas city chiefs minus
dude minus one and a half that's the
[ __ ] game dude oh
man i'm gonna tell you i can't wait for
that one i am telling you
despite what they said to my patriots i
am rooting hard for the [ __ ] buffalo
bills
uh i actually have the bills in the
super bowl i'm betting the bills i'm
taking the bills i think they are you
think they're gonna win at all
they're going to the super bowl against
the packers and the packers are going to
beat them
that's my
that's my super bowl
um all right let's break this down bill
we got cincinnati at tennessee tennessee
laying three and a half who you like
well you know i love my man joe burrow
i'm concerned about this is going to
come down to coaching
and i think uh tennessee's guys got a
little more [ __ ] uh the upper hand
there where's the game it's in tennessee
or in cincinnati it's in tennessee
tennessee's laying three and a half
tennessee's giving them three seasons
are we teasing here we're being little
[ __ ] here we are bedded straight up
um
you know what let's do one tease and
then we'll pick the other two games i
don't like that piece i don't like your
tease
you get one right in the locker room it
[ __ ] everybody over i like betting
individual games
all right
all right so we'll go you know what
since there's only four games this week
let's pick four
all right um
by the way i believe derek henry derrick
henry for tennessee is back and playing
and they said that he just passed the
full contact practice and he's fine
he can't be fine he's got to be 80 even
80 is scary
yeah that guy's like a linebacker with
the football dude
yeah that's a problem right there um
i like the bengals quarterback position
i like tennessee coach
running game
but tennessee's i mean cincinnati's got
a decent running game right who's their
running back they got a good guy back
there
um i think i like i like uh i like
cincy with the points
i just love joe burrow
that guy's the real [ __ ] deal i love
i i'm kind of betting with my audio i'll
take cincy
all right
well i also love that franchise because
i love this story
i love the whole story of that franchise
um well we're not going head-to-head
here so i'm just gonna pick i'm gonna
say the next game this is just in
anything better pics
so i'm gonna you know what i think
i i said for i think the packers are
winning it all they're minus five and a
half against the niners jimmy garoppolo
has a ripped up hand they don't know
what's going on with that so that means
that if his hand gets worse in the first
quarter of the game the new kid trey
lance comes in it's going to be too much
for him aaron rodgers his foot is better
they they had a week off
i think that they're tired of hearing
that they keep getting knocked out at
home i'm taking the packers big i mean
i'm this my farm bet it's my [ __ ]
farm bet dude i mean every time i've
said that i've lost
all right well here's what i'm thinking
nobody gives a [ __ ] that you're sick of
hearing it
you think the cowboys aren't sick of
hearing it nobody gives a [ __ ] you got
to go out win the [ __ ] game here's my
super bowl that i wanted to see
i want to see the bills against the
tampa bay buccaneers because the bills
beat bill belichick and then i want to
see
because they're going to it's the bills
dude this [ __ ] is either going to be
total 100 satisfaction finally
or
they're gonna go back with their [ __ ]
heads hanging low as always so i think
it's gonna be tampa bay
versus the buffalo bills
in this super bowl
see if they can slay both dragons bill
belichick three dragons bill belichick
tom brady and win a super bowl or does
tom brady
end their dreams again from another
conference paul
anyway here's the deal i'm taking um
if if if tampa was going to la i would
be worried but here's the thing tampa
played in la earlier this year and lost
you're skipping the packers though
packers niners you you're going with the
ball i don't know what you wanted me to
pick that oh what do i think of that
game yeah i like the pack because okay
all right so we just don't like that
that's sick
no one gives you [ __ ] 49ers don't care
that they're sick of [ __ ] losing the
thing is the packers are a better team
and he said jimmy g's [ __ ] knocked up
uh knocked up he's uh banged up a little
bit he's knocked up
he's three months pregnant three months
praise his first trimester
morning sickness right before the game
um i like tampa bay because they lost to
the rams already this year i don't think
that they're gonna get tom brady twice
i think tom is dialed in i think
everybody feels it
they feel his greatness they want to be
part of his last dance documentary
they want a part in it
that game to me is such a i just really
have no
yeah i mean i'll go with that listen go
with the goat with that minus three at
home
um and then i got the buffalo bills plus
one
plus one in kansas city and i want to
see that oh that's gonna be i know the
thing about that is you that that's you
betting with your heart you can't stand
kansas city you think they're overrated
listen no no listen to me
uh if you don't
don't call me during those hours because
i'm locked in oh i'm gonna be locked in
bill this is my thing about kansas city
i think they're taking a lot of
penalties am i crazy they take a lot of
[ __ ] penalties
you know i had the biggest stupidest
penalty last week
what the [ __ ] game was i watching this
guy [ __ ]
they were going for it on fourth down he
knocks the ball down
the corner does should have picked it
off knocks it down
and then takes his helmet off in
celebration and gave him a first down it
was just like good lord buddy
uh
all right that's a good thing i will um
i don't know that game is i i think
kansas city has a lot of pride paul and
i think that they're hearing what you're
saying about them and i don't think that
they like it
and as much as um
you know the patriots in kansas city had
a nice little rivalry there
i do respect the hell out of him and i
think patrick mahomes is not going to go
i don't think he's going to be the
problem though it might be their defense
i think just to fly they just it feels
like the bill's year doesn't it it just
feels like they're on a roll here the
bills looked so good last week they
looked so good every side of every part
of the game
um
josh that doesn't [ __ ] count dude
that doesn't be playing against the
[ __ ] rookie quarterback man come on
dude this is the thing about the
patriots they keep thinking bill
belichick dude we stuck last year
the fact that we even made it to the
playoffs was [ __ ] amazing we had a
rookie quarterback now
i kind of feel like we uh
it just the game just got away from us
and we had we had no way of [ __ ]
stopping it but
um i just like the way they mix the run
i don't think if they the bill's
stopping the [ __ ] out of the patriots
means that they're gonna stomp the [ __ ]
out of kansas city however if they do
that paul no i don't think they do that
no i i don't think they're going to
i would be nervous for your your boy
aaron rodgers and the green bay packers
i'll tell you the one team that i would
put everything on that would beat the i
mean we're getting ahead of ourselves
but in my opinion from what i'm saying
the team that will beat the chiefs no
doubt about it would be if the rams
played him in the super bowl because the
rams front four i think the rams have
good defensive backs you take out tyree
kill we're not there yet though um
well this is this is for the super bowl
kansas city versus [ __ ] uh
bill
it's the super bowl i mean as much as i
respect the titans i just don't feel uh
even if they want you know
joe burrows listening to you right now
in the locker room going we're going
we're smoking a stick with him at some
point
ah
yes it's gonna happen i'm just gonna
keep saying it's gonna happen so it's
gonna happen um all right yeah so i'll
take uh so we're taking cincy we're
taking the bills
we're taking the uh
the packers and the buccaneers no real
surprises there although the bills the
bill's um
bill's chiefs of the toss-up and i also
think graham's uh yeah i i could see
i could see the rams pulling that game
off and knocking brady in them out but
i'll roll with the i'll roll with
brady's record experience being home
there you go so there you guys have it
uh if you want to roll with us and have
a little fun
there you go go to bed mgm
um you download the app you use bonus
code burr b-u-r-r your first uh ten
dollar
look i tried to freestyle it
here's my pick paul three great games
one snooze
one snoozer i think the snooze is gonna
be the packers game just because jimmy
uh garoppolo is knocked up
that's what i keep saying
me and bill me and bill and everything
anything better podcast want to wish
jimmy garoppolo a safe pregnancy
we hope everything's so happy for you
we hope you give birth to a left tackle
all right guys so all you got to do is
download the bet mgm app you sign up
using bonus code burr burr first 10
money line bet um on any nfl uh game and
you'll receive 200 and free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome just sign up
and use bonus code uh burr oh let the
sunday night special
win some money for you
let the sunday night special
win some [ __ ] money for you
all right we're going to get back up on
you sitting on your i'm kidding good
we're going to uh
we're going to try to get back up on
this horse we we want to we won three
monday night specials during our season
and we need to win one for the playoffs
so we have playoffs so we have the san
francisco 49
playoffs san francisco 49ers and packers
so i think we both like the packers
minus five and a half we like the
packers to win that game by six
yep they cover five and a half and bill
the over
oh billy loves and over i love the over
all right
we'll do the over which is what what's
the under over andrew
46.
46 and a half all right
i like the or i like i'm seeing a lot of
lambo leaps i'm seeing maybe a 49ers
defensive touchdown on some weird
[ __ ] complaints there would be a lot
of people going to the end i don't know
though but jimmy uh
jimmy g's hurt though
um what about the weather there dude is
it going to be like 10 degrees
i don't know if the the over in that
weather you like it we'll go with it
[ __ ] it no no no last week i made all
the calls paul
i wouldn't hit you anymore what would
you like to say here paul
what are you
what are you thinking
do you think i'm in the under
paul it's going to be a bloodbath
version are you are you leaning under
the forecast is uh 13 degrees
that's the spring day
13 no it's it's it's sunny no no
indication 13 degrees and sunny yeah 40
46 and a half is such a perfect
[ __ ] number it's perfect um
you know what your instinct was over and
we said he's going to throw two so
that's you know let we'll go over man
let's root for some points paul you're
not acting like the champ here
you got to walk the walk you're going
with my instincts here i don't like this
all right we're going over
dude your instincts
all year have been fantastic and let's
be honest i limped into that i limped
into that i i don't feel like a champion
doesn't go oh and four luckily i had a
little bit of a game and a half you
don't i s you know what i did they were
like he's gonna win they were handing me
a water and i [ __ ] tripped but still
made it over the line
[Laughter]
all right guys this has been anything
better nfl um
preview for
the divisionals divisional playoffs
coming up this week enjoy the games bet
responsibly have fun with it and we will
see you guys uh next week visit
betmgm.com for terms and conditions 21
years of age and older to wager in
arizona colorado d.c iowa indiana
indiana louisiana michigan minnesota new
jersey nevada new york pennsylvania
tennessee virginia west virginia wyoming
and washington only all promotions are
subject to qualification and eligibility
requirements
rewards issued as non-withdrawal bets or
site credit free bets expire in seven
days from issuance excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step in arizona
1-800-522-4700 colorado dc louisiana
nevada wyoming west virginia
1-800-270-7117
for confidential help michigan 1-800
gambler indiana new jersey pennsylvania
and west virginia or 1-800 bets off in
iowa or call 877 eight uh
h-o-p-e-n-y that's eight seven seven
eight hope ny or text open y four six
seven three six nine new york call or
text the tennessee red line eight
hundred eight eight nine
seven 9789 tennessee or call
1-888-777-9696
minnesota or 1-800-547-6133
washington
all right there you go that's the
bet mgm
uh
clip of the week enjoy this music here
picked out by the wonderful andrew
themless and we have a bonus episode of
the monday morning uh sorry the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast that is it
god bless you have a great weekend you
can't
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
uh january 20th
2014 what's going on how are you
how was your week
did you enjoy yourself
did you survive the weekend and all the
big football games and all the screaming
and yelling there
um i had a [ __ ] and i had a great
weekend
i have to tell you that first of all
before uh before i get going uh just in
case there's any concern
i am okay
all right and i'm not talking about the
patriots losing oh geez yeah
i'm talking about
the [ __ ] fires in california
you know what's [ __ ] hilarious
one of the greatest things that can ever
happen to you
as far as you uh
that i spelled douche wrong my little
notes here douche on southwest
i spelt the d-o-u-c-h
let's see french spelling
um i'll get to that story later
um one of the greatest things you can do
as far as like understanding the news a
little better is when the big news story
is happening where you live
and you just watch how it's [ __ ]
reported
um
i i had a gig this weekend in uh in
albuquerque new mexico and uh you know
this time of year
the hills catch on fire
it happens every [ __ ] year this year
there's a drought so it's worse
all right but this happens
every [ __ ] year
and
the way they report this [ __ ]
they never just say that this is
completely natural that this is the
natural cycle
of of nature out here
basically what happens to recap because
i think i went through this before
basically what happens
is um here in southern california what
happens is uh
for like a month every year we get rain
it rains like a [ __ ] that
doesn't even rain like it pours a few
days and everybody freaks out and they
can't drive because it hasn't rained in
like 11 months so all the oil and
transmission and brake fluid
gets mixed in with the water and it's
it's actually it's a i would say it's a
like a little bit
slicker than it is back east but
everybody out here acts like they're
driving in two feet of snow it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
um
but anyways what happens all that water
comes and then all the hills all the
mountains all that [ __ ]
turns a beautiful color green
you know and it's lush and it's
beautiful looking and all that and then
basically the rain [ __ ] stops and
occasionally you will get rain
and uh then sometime around the summer
the [ __ ]
summer
um
i don't know like august september
whenever the october somewhere around
there we get what's known as the santa
ana winds there and they come in from
the east
and these [ __ ] things will like you
know if you had shutters they'd blow
them shut and open i mean they're really
strong winds especially if you're in the
hills a little bit
um because it's just flat land out here
what happens is it goes across the
mojave desert
all right and it picks up all that hot
air and it's basically like a giant hair
dryer and it dries out the [ __ ] hills
and then inevitably a fire starts
and it burns out all the brush
and then it starts anew lush and
beautiful every year but the problem is
is we've out [ __ ] the flatlands
the problem is we don't like living near
one another
problem is we like to have status
i want to look down on you i want to be
away from you your [ __ ] music's too
loud i don't like the smell of your food
i don't want my kids hanging out with
your kids so we move up into the [ __ ]
hills and next thing you know
rich people with [ __ ] gold bracelets
start getting eaten by bobcats or
whatever scratched up by them eaten by
mountain lions and their [ __ ] houses
burned down
but it is 100 natural and then what
always ends up happening is some [ __ ]
douche on the east coast
what is and it's not their fault because
when they show this [ __ ] on the news
you know i was out here and i went
through i went for a hike and i was able
to see out uh and i could see a fire out
in way out in pasadena
and uh it's [ __ ] amazing giant fire
and this type of [ __ ] but whatever it's
just
it's like [ __ ] i don't know 30 miles
away or whatever 20 miles away
it's not a problem but i landed in
albuquerque and
they were showing the fires
and the way they were talking about them
you would have thought the entire state
was engulfed in flames i had like five
people call me to make sure i was all
right hey you know i'm seeing this i'm
seeing the stuff in the nose i'm just
making sure like the whole [ __ ] state
is on fire like we're all out here
with our [ __ ] garden hoses
um
and they just completely zoom in on the
fire and that's exactly what it looks
like it literally looks like hell on
earth
um it reminds me of when i lived back
east and there would be a hurricane it
actually was downgraded to a tropical
storm then it just kind of rained do you
remember that news clip where that woman
was in the boat you know acting like she
was in four feet of water and then those
construction workers came walking by and
it was like
it was like [ __ ] ankle deep
that's what they do so um
i'm just like you know california's
beautiful [ __ ] state uh it's not on
fire
the fires are natural
um as they are with all forests
i don't i know i'm not a [ __ ] nature
guy i don't know it to that level but i
do know it burns it all out and it
causes it to come back even more
healthier every [ __ ] year now if you
want to be
you know a gambler and build a house
in the middle of the [ __ ]
you know there's a chance one day it
might burn down
all right but uh actually you know what
i i'm
i'm [ __ ] up here i should just roll
with it and act like the entire place is
on fire maybe less people will move out
here and we can drive a little uh
we can drive a little more
but uh verzi actually sent me a text he
said he was watching the la fires or
whatever the the california fires
and he was just saying like uh you know
the usual that's god's way of saying
you shouldn't live out there you know
meanwhile he lives in [ __ ] new york
you know what's [ __ ] up about new york
and why people are way more polite than
they give them uh credit for when you're
on the subway
pretty much people are polite
because
you're all mixed in together and you
have no idea
who or what is next to you and what the
[ __ ] they did in the last 24 hours
forget about the last 24 minutes they
could have just stabbed somebody
they could have somebody [ __ ] locked
in the closet and they're [ __ ] apart
you have no [ __ ] idea so generally
speaking
uh you're on your best behavior when
you're on the uh subway
but um
you know
i don't [ __ ] know you know
they always just show all the worse it's
a [ __ ] great state and whatever
catches on fire i mean we have to we
have something has to happen to pay for
the fact that it's 60 degrees out and i
don't have to shovel my car
out of the [ __ ] parking spot
right
so i'll just let you know in case you
were concerned in case you were thinking
like hey i always wanted to move to
california but the entire state is
engulfed in flames once a year that
isn't true uh yes we are having a
drought um and i don't know if that has
to do with just the natural cycle or the
fact that there's over seven billion
people getting up every day and they
gotta take a [ __ ] and ask to go
somewhere and maybe eventually that
leads to uh a drought i have no [ __ ]
idea but i'm just letting you know the
whole [ __ ] state isn't on fire all
right so in the words of martin short
relax your crack
um
okay so anyways this is the uh the
monday morning podcast
oh and i got it so i gotta i gotta talk
about the douche on southwest so um
i went to albuquerque this weekend and i
had a [ __ ] unbelievable time i have
not been back there since uh all those
wonderful episodes
of uh breaking bad that i got to be on
and um
you know i was gonna go on a hike that's
what i wanted to do i wanted to do that
but uh
you know nia had some friends out there
we were gonna go to lunch
you know how that is it'll only take
like an hour
that's three hours
you know so i'm just like i'm too
[ __ ] old to um
i'm too old to [ __ ] hike and have a
social event
in one day and then actually give any
sort of a decent decent uh performance
so i was like all right [ __ ] it i'm not
gonna go on the hike i'll go over and we
met um i met nia's friends and they were
they were awesome [ __ ] cooked up
burgers
the middle of the day you know those
homemade burgers that are way bigger
than the ones that you get in a
restaurant and then you eat them and uh
you don't feel 60 or some stomach
afterwards
it's [ __ ] phenomenal
and uh the people's house we went over
to they had all these beers and that
type of stuff and i stayed away i was a
good boy so i could have the show but i
know myself at this point so i still
that i ca i can't do all of those
activities in one day so i just decided
like uh all right i'll just do the
social thing
and i'll chill out which was actually
really cool because i've been to
albuquerque a bunch of times and i never
got to ride around
and uh
see any of it
and uh it's really really [ __ ] cool
place man really really cool
um so anyway so that night i was at the
uh the 66 casino
meaning basically route 66 and uh one of
the coolest looking casinos i've i've
seen i'll try to have some images up for
you you know you try to take pictures of
those
casino lights and it never comes out on
your cell phone at least the one that i
have the 4f
um
but it was really cool like the hotel
had like that you know
the route 66 sign instead of the 66 it
just said hotel it was all lit up and
then you know it's native americans own
it and then the the the arrows pointing
in where to go were literally like
arrows and they looked like they were
stuck into the ground they were all lit
up it was [ __ ] badass
it was badass
and then i got to play in the the name
of the theater was the legends theater
[Laughter]
i played a place called the legends
theater i remember i was doing some
press for it and they said what can
people expect when they come down
to the legends theater and it's like
well they should expect to see a legend
they shouldn't expect to see me go fresh
out of the [ __ ] horse stable
where do i go is this the way to the
green room
is there going to be a lot of people i'm
scared
uh fortunately it all went it went great
and uh
[ __ ] great people out there man once
again and this was another place that
was supposed to be a stop
on the uh billy red state tour
and uh i don't know for any comics who
are listening to this don't
buy into that horseshit that these are
flyover states they're beautiful places
to go and the people are ridiculously
appreciative that you showed up
they're psyched and they always say the
same [ __ ] can you tell this person tell
this person
you know they're always asking for jim
norton and all these guys that i know
from the opium anthony show telling them
to come out there
you know we like comedy too so i passed
the word on to them and a lot of them
have uh started coming out which is cool
um
i just hope that they don't become uh
and all jaded like when you play like
the bigger cities and just like whatever
whatever man you know i got other things
to do man
um it was great and they actually bought
a bunch of dvds which is phenomenal
because i got a bunch of them sitting in
my garage i feel like my garage is
filled with [ __ ] laser discs
i got to get those things out of there
um
anyways
so oh the douche on southwest sorry i'm
all over the place today
so we're flying back
um quick flight back hour 45 minutes
[ __ ] phenomenal
and uh you know the southwest people
they always try to be funny put a smile
on your face most times they're not
and this guy was actually kind of funny
then we go to land we we're landing in
los angeles and this [ __ ] [ __ ]
gets on the the [ __ ] mic and starts
going you know
he's like going welcome to los angeles
which is a uh
interesting place
yes
very
interesting
he kept doing this weird laugh
and i'm looking at nia first of all it
sounded creepy as [ __ ] in hell
um
i don't want to be homophobic but the
guy sounded gay
you know the gay accent
so i used to do a joke on this like gay
people come from all 50 states yet
they they kind of all have the same
accent which isn't true but generally
speaking there is a gay accent which
makes no sense
how did that joke that's how that joke
used to go
like if you were gay from alabama you'd
be like hey buddy i'd really like to
suck your dick like that's the way
you should sound
to do a stereotypical redneck accent
with my stereotypical gay action right
but they don't
i grew up in alabama and let's just say
i'm not going back there
it's probably more valley girl you know
what the [ __ ] i'm saying that's what the
guy sounded like so i'm just sitting
there in the back going like did uh you
know this guy get blown in west
hollywood and somebody stole his wallet
did he want to be the next jim j uh
buffins whatever the [ __ ] the guy's name
is from too close for comfort i don't
know what his [ __ ] deal was
but i'm just sitting there in my head
going
yet another the most [ __ ] up thing
about living in los angeles i've never
lived in a city where everybody trashes
it
everybody just shits on it and it kills
me about that that's this is the only
[ __ ] city where you could do that i
guess you can kind of make like a
gambling joke but you can actually land
in los angeles not give a [ __ ] that
everybody there lives
on the plane for the most part lives
there and then just [ __ ] on it
um
ah they can't [ __ ] draw me nuts
what's driving me [ __ ] it's a
interesting place that's just like what
the [ __ ] are you doing what makes you
such a good person
what happened to you here huh
what sitcom did you test for and you got
too coked up the night before and you
[ __ ] blew it huh what were you
supposed to be on will and grace there
um
sorry
you know what it is i'm defensive of l.a
at this point because i have to live out
here because this is the [ __ ]
business i don't have to but you know it
makes life a lot [ __ ] easier
to be
where everybody else is in this business
you know if i was into [ __ ] computers
i'd go move up to uh the [ __ ] uh the
valley up there the silicon valley
which for the life of me i don't know
why they call it silicone
isn't that what's in fake titties
is it i don't [ __ ] know anyways let's
do a little bit of advertising here oh
thanks to everybody who listened to the
uh very special
um
bonus podcast this week with jay moore
if he didn't listen to it and he always
wondered what harvey keitel would sound
like doing bad 80s stand-up it's a
muscleless
it really is a must listen nothing but
rave reviews
uh
other than one one person one person
[ __ ] on it
was saying how lame
uh jaymore was and he called him j snore
so literally this person is telling me
that my guest is lame and then his joke
is a pun
you know that kind of kind of kills your
credibility uh
i think jay's a [ __ ] genius man
my face actually hurt from smiling by
the end of it
these [ __ ] ridiculous impressions
um so please have a listen to that you
know i'm gonna kill a couple hours for
you this week in your cubicle there all
right dollar shave club everybody
dollar shave club all right for a couple
of bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your front door
not only does it save you a ton of cash
it saves you from trudging you're sorry
ass to the drugstore for a pack of
blades i always get stuck behind the
lady
paying with all the loose change from
the car ashtray with her blue wig
uh it's like she thinks exact change is
a requirement
um
i can't why do i always try to read that
says i'm a patient person but heck i
came in with scruff now i'm leaving with
the full beard we get it i'm there for a
long time we all know you go in there
drug stores are the absolute worst it's
just a complete cross-pollination of
everybody from alcoholics and drug
addicts i was in the the cvs the other
day or the dwayne
reed dwayne aid whatever the [ __ ] they
have out here
and this [ __ ] dude
came in with just pants on
that's it just pants on he didn't have
on any underwear because i could see at
least three quarters of his ass crack
hanging out of the back of his [ __ ]
pants and he wasn't even that fat he had
a bare belly but he still had his he
still had his high school hips
or maybe he just pushed his [ __ ]
corduroys down that [ __ ]
you know
so he walks out i walk out behind him he
has a dollar in his hand
and for some reason he [ __ ] spits a
glob of spit on it and then sticks it to
the side of the of the uh the cvs duane
reed [ __ ] thing there right and then
walks away and within two seconds it
blew down on the ground
and i was just like well i guess that's
what i would do if i didn't have a
wallet
i have no idea but i don't want to look
at that that's why dollar shave club
everybody
um right now dollar shave club for a
couple of bucks a month you can avoid
that nightmare and you get amazing
quality razor blades delivered right to
your door they can't make it any easier
that's right no more wasting time and no
more getting hit up for 20 bucks every
time you buy razors everybody here
meeting me is getting their dollar shave
club blades and you know what you should
too you don't have to but you should i
want to make your life easier here's a
genius idea try replacing your old
shaving cream with dr
from dollarshaveclub.com trust me your
face will thank you later don't waste
time at the drugstore behind a lady
paying in pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
or go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner keep your
stress level low and your bank account
hi
shave time shave money go to dollar
shave club dot com forward slash burr
uh there you go
you know it's funny every time i say
keep your uh
your your stress level low and your bank
account balance high i point i point
down and then i point up
i don't know why desperately trying to
help myself have a good read
it's part of my ritual
okay hulu plus hulu plus everybody
you've probably tried hulu.com unless
you're living under a rock
now with hulu plus you can watch your
favorite shows anytime anywhere hulu
plus lets you watch thousands of hit tv
shows and a selection of acclaimed
movies on your television or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet and it
all streams in hd for the best viewing
experience with hulu plus you can watch
your favorite current tv shows like
saturday night live community and family
guy you can also check out exclusive
content including hulu originals like
the awesomes starring snl seth mayas and
moon boy starring chris o'dowd from
bridesmaid
uh bridesmaids hulu plus also offers a
great selection of acclaimed films for
only 7.99 a month you can stream as many
tv shows and movies as you want wherever
you want right now you can try hulu plus
for free for two weeks when you go to
huluplus.com
that's a special offer from my listeners
make sure you use hulu plus dot com
slash bill so you get an extended free
trial and that they know that we send
you go to huluplus.com bill now or click
the hulu plus banner on the podcast page
at billboard.com
all right there you go there's two two
reads two down what do i got to go one
two all right two and two
two and two this week people
two and two we gotta find ourselves a
new kind of energy
all right what to talk about next um
oh this week
oh billy redface
oh alabaster chest
oh milky legs himself
it's gonna be out in hawaii
honolulu hawaii i'm doing a show out
there on friday night
and it's just me myself and i
um i don't have an opener
uh it's just gonna be me and uh i'm
gonna be doing a whole bunch of material
because i'm getting ready to do a
special this year baby getting ready to
do another one i gotta be honest with
you i don't know what i'm gonna put it
out on
i feel like i still have to make dvds
for people my age and on up
who like to have the hard copy
you know did i mention that nia hooked
up our stereo
um
i bought her this stereo when we first
started dating
it was one of the i think our first
christmas together that's what i got her
and i was sitting there going like i
don't know if she's gonna like this but
um
she seemed like sort of an artsy nerd
like me
and uh i'm not really artsy whatever i'm
a [ __ ] nerd i get into [ __ ]
and um
i took a shot she absolutely [ __ ]
flipped out she loved it
so she was living you know i wasn't
living with me at the time and i hooked
it up
and i don't know what happened i forgot
how to do it the wires got crossed
through moving i don't know a few years
ago when we were still living in an
apartment
was the last time i hooked it up
properly and i don't know what was going
on i couldn't figure the [ __ ] thing
out when we moved into our house so it's
just been sitting there and i think it
was a few years old i thought it was
broken so i go on the road
uh when i come back
she had the whole thing set up
and was playing like some pink floyd and
all this type it was [ __ ] awesome and
emasculating all at the same time
and
um how the [ __ ] did i get into that i
was just going to hawaii what the hell
was my point there
i don't [ __ ] know oh i know yeah i
was talking about what am i going to put
out my uh
my new album on
i have no idea
oh maybe like you know people will still
like dvds i have no idea i'm still gonna
burn off some i can tell you right now
i'm not gonna make five thousand of them
i have 4 500 of them sitting in my
[ __ ] garage like i have a second car
that doesn't go anywhere
oh jesus you know one of my goals in
life is is to have a clean garage
i don't want to be that guy that has the
[ __ ] garage that you can't even put
the car in
um thank god i got my old truck sitting
in there so that takes up most of it
i gotta pull you guys want to hear about
my garage we'll go around the garage
i got my 68 f-100
three on the tree over there
and then i got the uh i got a i got a
pull-up dip station
and then on the ground there's this
thing for push-ups if you want but i
still have those perfect push-ups
things i don't know if they're perfect
but they're [ __ ] hard i can tell you
that
and
um then what else do i have
i have a
10 or a 12 speed bike
that i bought when i was like in either
i think the ninth ninth grade
i've had it forever i still ride the
[ __ ] tank every once in a while
um
can anybody explain to me why if you
don't if you ride a bicycle every day it
doesn't really need air in the tires but
if you just let it sit there the air
goes out of them
can you guys answer some just some
day-to-day simple
like
science questions for me that i don't
understand how come i can lay on a couch
for four hours catatonic barely moving
and i'm fine
but if i fall asleep for five minutes on
the couch at my i wake up like oh it's
chilly and i need a blanket
i mean it's just shifting my weight
every five minutes is that enough to
keep my body temperature up that i don't
need a blanket
it could be the middle of the [ __ ]
summer
i mean unless there's a bunch of
humidity and you don't have ac or
whatever i'm just saying it could be
just perfectly comfortable could be like
goddamn 72 degrees perfect weather
in your goddamn living room any me
anyways and if i if i fall asleep for
more than five seven minutes i wake up
and my shoulders are cold and i gotta
put a blanket on i have to grab a little
blankie like a little twinkle toes there
um why is that
what else
what else is there i know i have a bunch
of these little ones that i just don't
understand those are two
if someone could explain the same thing
with the car if you leave it sitting
there too long the air goes out of the
tires they become flat after a while
does the air fill not needed
well i don't think this guy's coming
back
go somewhere else
i don't know i know i sound like a [ __ ]
go [ __ ] yourself um
so anyways i'm gonna be in hawaii this
weekend
which uh i'm really excited about and um
i'm gonna go to the pro bowl this year
so look for me be wearing a robin
williams hawaiian shirt
um
drinking some millers
and uh
i think it's gonna be a fun game this
year i like that they're choosing
upsides i heard that they're not it's
not gonna be nfc versus afc they're
gonna choose upsides and then they're
not going to have kickoffs which i think
is good because it's such a weird
like
it's you can't play the game because no
one wants to get hurt i think they
should just play flag football
they should just play flag football and
they should just mic up the players
because you can play hockey and all-star
game and hockey you can just play you
just play you know basically non-contact
not going too hard and guys can still
entertain the crowd with the stick
handling the shots and all that type of
stuff same thing with basketball
um you don't have to go that hard and
everybody can watch a 150 to 145 game
and baseball the baseball all-star game
is the best because it actually means
something and they actually come out and
play
um
but you know it's a non-contact sport
what are you gonna do you know unless
somebody tries to beat you with the ball
or if you're talking about the ball
hitting the bat there
um
so anyways i i'm gonna be out there and
uh gonna be doing probably at least an
hour and a half on stage because i gotta
i gotta blow it out and then tighten it
up right before um
my uh
my special comes out
and then i'm gonna weed out the weak
ones it's like making an nfl roster and
i probably got you know 55 guys on it
and i got to cut was it like 10 of them
12 of them i don't [ __ ] know but uh a
couple you guys been asking me still
have been asking me um about when my
carnegie hall album is coming out uh
we're on the final stages and hopefully
it's going to be out may june
it took forever
um because i was dealing with
uh you know
carnegie's very prestigious place they
got to make sure all the
eyes and dot and the t's are crossed
whatever the [ __ ] expression is so
it's it's been very long and very
tedious and uh but eventually it is
coming out and i'm gonna be psyched and
it's only coming out on album only so
get your stereos today
and um you know and if some of you gonna
be like well how come you won't put it
on all this stuff
because there's too much overlapping
material between that and it's basically
the hour i was doing when i was leading
up to recording my last special so i
don't want to [ __ ] people over
and put out you know two dvds of the
same [ __ ] thing or a cd that's the
same as the dvd so i'm letting you know
right now
it's like three quarters the same
material
i tell it differently every night but
basically it's the same [ __ ] there's a
couple extra lines and maybe some lines
from the special that isn't in there and
then there's a chunk of [ __ ] that uh
didn't make the special for whatever
[ __ ] reason and it's only coming out
on vinyl
there i've told you what the deal is so
don't come crying to me afterwards
um
is that the worst selling job of a
[ __ ] album ever
um all right
so what am i talking about all right
let's get down to the pro football this
week everybody
pro football oh jesus um
let's see what are we gonna say all
right that first game like i kind of
went the the patriots
broncos kind of went the way that i
thought it was going to go uh i didn't
think that we were going to win
and uh congratulations to the broncos
they definitely were the best team in
the afc
this year and um um
i uh i don't know i still saw some
articles out there i'm i'm surprised at
how many people who write and talk about
sports
that uh
talked about you know the disappointing
end of the patriots season and
everything i mean i just feel like well
what they were working with that was one
of the best seasons i've seen belichick
brady
have um i never would have thought
in september where the [ __ ] we were at i
would never would have thought that we
we could have uh
gotten as far as we did and uh you know
so i'm looking at it like a success i
saw some
great up and coming stars on defense and
i'm looking forward to next year
and uh and i'm actually psyched that the
broncos in a way i'm psyched i never
like seeing my team lose but i'm psyched
that they are because you know peyton
manning that [ __ ] unbelievable
offense they got a really solid defense
they should be there i want to see a
good super bowl
and um
i know belichick was complaining about
uh welker's and i'm gonna use air quotes
hit
on talib i didn't think that it was uh i
mean i don't know the game the way he
does but i didn't look dirty to me at
all if anything looked like he got the
worst of the hit initially it looked
like he was trying to get out of the way
um i've never known welker to do
anything he never did any of that dirty
[ __ ]
he's a little fella out there with a
giant football helmet now was he wearing
like an anti-concussion
for the rest of my life helmet did
anybody else notice that his helmet was
like a third bigger than it usually had
he looked like he looked like is it
kazoo
and the flintstones
his head look look at his helmet was
[ __ ] eating his head
i was like oh look at look look at wes
welker way in there in that helmet
um
but anyways the uh
i know the broncos look really really
really strong yesterday and uh you know
this was a tough year for me to watch
football because i got married and then
i also spent three weeks in europe so i
don't even know guys [ __ ] name all i
can tell you is that 88 that 80 [ __ ]
killed us
uh especially that [ __ ] 88 like and i
swear to god like
this guy had four catches like a hundred
yards
within like a quarter it seemed i just
remember by the time he caught that
fourth one i'm literally sitting there
on the couch going are they gonna
[ __ ] cover that guy
is it is it still a mystery what the
[ __ ] is going on 88.
do something about 88
right
um hanging in there rooting for the team
and all that type of [ __ ] oh you know
what you know what's funny was i was on
the uh the southwest flight with the
douche trash in la when the game started
and i taped the game i idiot and i i had
my phone off i put my headphones on in
the airport pulled my hat down walked by
all the bars didn't look at anything had
the music cranked when i was sitting at
the little turn style waiting for my bag
and i somehow i was able with all the
technology and all the streaming [ __ ] i
was able to get home and having no idea
who was doing what ran into the house
sat down and i was able to put it on
and um
and it was great
because
i got to fast forward through all the
commercials i got to fast forward
through half time
and i got to watch this just you know
this great game everybody wasn't a great
game i mean uh
the broncos really dominated
even though we were in it
somehow in the end i'll get back to that
later
um
but anyways so congratulations to the
broncos and all that [ __ ] and uh good
for peyton mann because you know i read
something where he was you know his neck
was all [ __ ] up he didn't know if he
was going to play again so he seems
really psyched obviously to be back so
good on him um and then on to um
seattle
49ers
which i felt was the super bowl
and um kind of still feel that way i
felt like whoever won that game was
gonna be uh
i just you know it's just the the ebb
and flow of the conferences there's
always one conference that is stronger
and um
i don't know it was a [ __ ]
heavyweight battle man just a great game
and fortunately
there was only a couple of those soccer
mom
um
[ __ ] [ __ ] calls like that that
that one that they called in the first
quarter had me up off the couch
um
that unnecessary roughness was uh was
against the 49ers i mean it was just a
textbook
lead with your shoulder
wasn't helmet to helmet
and troy aikman goes well he does launch
himself it's like troy he has how else
do you tackle
you're supposed to you got to launch
yourself at the target
i i that was one of the worst [ __ ]
calls i think eventually they said it
was a bad call
it was perfect
but those are those [ __ ] calls man
that i i think that's yet another reason
why all of dan marino's records are
falling
because
that should have been the end of the
drive
um i think it was third down i don't
remember but
but generally speaking it ends a drive
an incomplete pass and then they call
unnecessary reference roughness it keeps
the drive going and then the quarterback
gets to continue throwing the ball down
the field adding more yards to their
resume
um in this era when you can't really
cover a receiver past five yards you
can't even look at them or you get a
[ __ ] flag fortunately there was only
a couple of those calls
um
and obviously there's gonna be a rule
change with um
i really should know the names of these
guys i just don't this year i've just
been [ __ ] traveling so much but uh
uh the guy in the 49ers this is so
disrespectful because he gave up his
goddamn knee to make the play he
recovered the fumble he was
he was
touched by a seattle player it should
have been
a turnover but uh fortunately was
justice where they uh
seattle turned over the ball a couple
plays later so what they really just got
[ __ ] out of about 30 seconds on the
clock
but um
i don't know it was just an awesome
awesome awesome [ __ ] game
and um
i don't know i i think
in the end i just think kaepernick his
inexperience
um
kind of caught up with him a little bit
just some of the decisions that he made
but
but that guy is the real deal and he's
not afraid of the moment so i just think
that unfortunately for 49ers fans
they're going to have to wait at least
another year but i think that that guy's
got
he definitely has what it takes man um
he's definitely a winner and that type
of thing so it was just it was a great
[ __ ] game
and um
so now we're into the super bowl
now we're into the super bowl so now you
have to wonder
you got to wonder right
if you like me
um
all i want to do is see the [ __ ] game
i don't want to listen to the the
pre-game and post-game analysis
you know there's always one person
that's going to make you know all the
quotes and all that type of [ __ ] and
yadda yadda yadda yadda yadda so this is
what i do this is all you got to do if
you just want to watch the [ __ ] game
um
i would um
just put on the nhl network for the next
two weeks is basically what you want to
do
get into nhl hockey you won't have to
watch any of the [ __ ] analysis
where they're going to go the entire
roller coaster
um
i don't it's just lazy journalism and
whoever talks [ __ ] and that type of
thing they're gonna get a hundred
percent of the [ __ ] attention
and it's just gonna it's just it's
absolutely [ __ ]
nauseating like um
yesterday you know at the end of the
game the seattle uh 49ers game i felt
like uh tommy lee jones in no country
for old men where it just sort of has
passed you by and you can't even make
sense of it anymore
um
i gotta tell you i talked about this on
on forrest shaw's and al jackson's
podcast what the [ __ ] is it called jesus
christ i'm so old i can't remember
anything anymore
um
whatever just google that you'll find it
i talked about that that [ __ ] now how
everybody
whether you catch a four-yard pass or
you hit a layup
and you get fouled and it goes in like
all these athletes now they got to do
that stupid [ __ ]
they do that yell like they're in 300
like they just slayed a dragon
hit a [ __ ] layup ticky tack foul and
won even pau gasol does it now
what is that
that it's [ __ ] the stupidest did
jerry rice ever do that did jordan ever
[ __ ] do that
you know
it's [ __ ] hilarious
i saw uh who was it yesterday was it
golden tate is a great [ __ ] receiver
critical moment in the game they need a
first down it catches the ball he has
first down yardage i don't know if he
didn't know where he was on the field
but
rather than just dropping to the ground
he cuts back inside now he's behind the
first down line and then has to fight
like hell to get across so he basically
makes the play
[ __ ] it up and is able to recover and
then he gets up
screaming like
he's god's gift
i got to tell you this right now this is
why
marshawn lynch is
might be my favorite player favorite
athlete
out there because the fact that he's
doing what he's doing every week
and i guess he
my buddy was telling me he just said i'm
not talking to the media this year and
got fined 50 grand and he didn't give a
[ __ ]
all he wants to do is win the goddamn
game
like that guy and that guy just runs
over people
and gets up basically gets i'm not
saying he doesn't celebrate a touchdown
but he just gets up and walks back to
the huddle
i love that [ __ ]
and as much as they're gonna talk about
um
or what's his face there
for running his yap i have to tell you
a cornerback is not going to win the
super bowl for you he can shut down that
part of the field but what can i i think
what's going to be the difference in the
super bowl
is going to be i think it's going to be
marshawn lynch because i think
seattle has a better defense
but the broncos have also have a really
strong defense
so
um
i give the nod to seattle there but it's
not this such a giant gap that the game
is over
all right and then when you go to the
quarterback position obviously
um
you got peyton manning
okay
and seattle's best weapon against peyton
manning is not their defense it's
actually marshawn lynch
okay peyton manning
the way he's playing this year
playing that guy is basically it would
be like if you owned a poisonous snake
all right
and you got to take it out of the tank
to [ __ ] clean the goddamn tank
and no matter how careful you are
eventually you're going to get bit by
that [ __ ]
the only way not to get bit by that
[ __ ] is to keep the son of a [ __ ] in
the tank and the best way to do that is
with a great running game
okay
and
i've seen this before
in past in in uh
championship games we have this
unstoppable quarterback and the guy's
sitting on the [ __ ] bench he's not
even sweating he's been there so [ __ ]
long because the other team is just
running the ball
and my big knock against the broncos
despite the fact that they are a great
team
is that they don't put people away
they had both against san diego and the
patriots they for the most part
dominated the game but at the end of the
[ __ ] game
they let they let the charges hang
around they even let us hang around like
if we made that two-point conversion
that onside kick
if we get it we can actually drive down
the field and somehow
could tie it like that's the situation
they were in after absolutely dominating
the game with like four minutes to go
whatever they were still in that
situation and i don't know i think that
eventually bites you in the ass so um
i don't know i just think that it's
gonna be uh
i think marshawn lynch is gonna be the
difference
if they are gonna and obviously their
offensive line but uh they only need to
open the smallest of hole
and that guy is just
i don't know it's the he's like this
devastating combination of like earl
campbell
and like walter payton i mean he's
[ __ ] unbelievable
and um and with that so what you're
gonna be now is you're gonna be
inundated with people uh
you know talking about uh what's his
face there
uh shannon sharp
sherman they're gonna be talking about
this guy up and down up and down the
brash outspoken they'll go all the way
once they've exhausted that and then
they'll be like is is it but is it an
inferiority complex
and then they'll get tired of doing that
and then they'll talk about his
upbringing and they'll say whether his
father was there whether his father
wasn't there and yada yada all that
[ __ ] horse [ __ ] so what i do
for the two weeks in between is i just
watch hockey
all right this is how you do it you just
[ __ ] watch
you watch hockey or whatever go work out
for two weeks get yourself in great
shape because you know you're gonna eat
like [ __ ]
during the super bowl
and just
don't put on sportscenter
just don't watch the [ __ ] unless you're
into it i'm i'm not into it i think if
you're one of those people who watches
the game with a jersey on at home and
you put eyeliner under your eyes and you
yell things like all day all day at your
tv i think you actually want to watch
the super bowl coverage but uh if you're
a [ __ ] regular fan
which i actually came to a piece here
with seattle fans because i was looking
at seattle fans the way people look at
like
the fires out here in california it
wasn't fair how i was looking at them
because they weren't showing the
die-hards they were showing the
jerk-offs like did you see that guy in
the lime green pimp suit you know what i
mean where the [ __ ] is that guy been
you know
come on
who does that what kind of a real
[ __ ] fan
does that you just go to the goddamn
game you watch the [ __ ] game you put
a little money on it you drink some
[ __ ] beers
whatever crack jokes or whatever and you
watch the [ __ ] game so
anyways
um
so this is our watch again basically i i
don't
i watch nhl hockey and then this year
i'm not going to a super bowl party i'm
going to be at home
and uh
what i love doing i told you guys this
last year is you start the game
like 90 minutes
after it started
just wait like an hour and a half
have a couple people over who really
like football you have a couple of beers
you shoot the [ __ ]
blah blah blah blah you got the grill
going and all that type of thing and
about an hour and a half in
you fast forward through all of the crap
in the beginning which i think is gonna
be the chili peppers i actually like the
two music bruno mars and uh music acts
they have bruno mars and the chili
peppers but i i'm there to watch the
game
you know what i mean
if i went to see either one of those
bands play and like halfway through it
they played a little bit of touch
football in the middle of it that would
also be annoying
um
so you fast forward through all of that
crap
and then the person you know trying to
make a record career out of singing the
national anthem you fast forward through
all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] now you're into
the game
you can fast forward through all the
stupid [ __ ] commercials he just
watched the game
and then you get to fast forward through
all of the half time
and then basically you catch up
somewhere in like the third quarter
um
at which point the game is really
starting to get tense because you know a
championship is on the line that's
basically
how i do it um if if you uh if you like
me
if you're the tommy lee jones
of uh
of sports fans at this point and you
can't even remotely relate
to what happened at the end of the game
yesterday
like why you would do that
and how it was actually mildly
depressing
like is that's gonna be the new thing
that you have to do um
i don't know
i don't [ __ ] know i just hope that
that uh
i hope that that's just a unique
personality and that everybody doesn't
start doing that because uh
i don't know you play sports you [ __ ]
try to kick the [ __ ] out of the guy and
in the end you just go hey good game
that's what you do
nobody choked in that game yesterday
that was a [ __ ] great game and i just
felt like that whole
all of that crap it just
took away from i had i watched a great
game and now i gotta sit there and
listen to all these [ __ ] lazy
journalists who are all gonna like moths
to a [ __ ] light are all gonna go up
to that
complete non-fucking story
it's just a non-fucking story anyways
um with that with that let's get to more
uh let's get to more advertising oh and
by the way seattle you know you might
finally have something to cheer about
you guys are one [ __ ] game away
and if you guys win i hope you
understand how ridiculous that loudest
crowd thing was all right and retiring
your jersey
[Music]
you're retiring your [ __ ] come on
real football fans of seattle come on
they retired your number
i mean are you guys all dying out there
and there was some sort of make-a-wish
thing that they had to do for you i mean
i just i can't get past that
and the fact that the team's never won a
championship
what are they saying
i don't i don't i don't understand it so
hopefully
you know either way it's going to be a
it's going to be a great thing to see
um either see peyton manning win one win
another one
uh
which you know
it reminds me when john elway who also
played for the broncos maybe that's a
little storyline they could run with
and and then the other thing is seattle
finally wednesday uh
finally wins the super bowl gets the
monkey off their back
either way it's it's gonna be uh it's
gonna be a good thing and uh i will
definitely have
be fast forwarding through commercials
and i will not be watching any post game
or any of that [ __ ] crap
uh mute button will be right at the
fingertips
oh billy lee jones
i'm trying to i'm trying to what i'm
trying to do is through modern
technology still make it seem like what
it was like when i watched the super
bowl in the the late 70s early 80s where
it was just the [ __ ] game uh
you know i just sound like a grumpy old
man and you know what i'm you're right i
am i am but either way congratulations
to uh the broncos in the seahawks it's
uh you know
this is the i i like that there's no
real underdog you got the two two really
kind of the best teams
although i really felt the 49ers also
yeah they should have been there too um
that's why i felt nfc was the super bowl
but whatever it's still going to be
hopefully it's going to be an awesome
[ __ ] game
and uh
you know there'll be nobody wigging out
either
at the end of the [ __ ] game i
literally thought that dude was going to
start crying
you don't even talk about me
um
that's [ __ ] uncomfortable
uncomfortable
is hell that was like seeing the nerd
finally beat up the bully you know when
you finally ball up your fist you punch
him and you win the fight
you're almost crying
it was just i don't know
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know what
what has happened to sports
can we hey espn can we
you know 100 access can you dial it back
down to like maybe 40 access
can you stop interviewing [ __ ]
coaches
fox and whatever nbc as they're jogging
off the field trying to think of their
halftime adjustments can we just stop
[ __ ] doing that i i don't give a [ __ ]
nhl can we stop interviewing players
in between the [ __ ] uh
periods is just sitting there still out
of breath from their last shift and that
[ __ ] drop of [ __ ] sweat hanging
off their nose looking like snot that
they have to keep wiping and then it
comes back again can we just enough i
don't give a [ __ ]
what happened in that first period i
just watched the first period i know
what happened what do you think you have
to do in the second period um oh maybe
score more goals
if any nhl players listen to this uh
i'll give you a free podcast t-shirt
even though you're gonna get fined
probably a hundred grand by the league
is there any way you could wipe your
nose on the blouse of the person who's
interviewing you in between periods
just reach out and grab that tie
and just dab your eyes
you know i got nothing to give you
you're a millionaire athlete but could
you just do it for the just for the
[ __ ] ridiculousness of it
like they're not going to interview you
after the [ __ ] game like i have to
have it they got that [ __ ] guy who
stands down there and what looks like
the penalty box in between the [ __ ]
benches
whatever the [ __ ] his name is prince
fielder the hell is his name
prince harry standing down there well
i'll tell you it's really starting to
eat up down here on the ice like why do
i need to hear that guy
poor bastard's got to stand up for three
periods and his loafers he's probably
got hammer toes by the end of the year
less access do you think you could do
that do you think you could actually
start a sports network that could
compete with espn and the whole thing is
less access
you know no miced up players
you just [ __ ] uh just trim the fat
can i just go back to watching bob lobel
at the end of the news and just seeing
five minutes of the [ __ ] can i just see
that
as he sits there in a [ __ ] blazer
you know every once in a while takes a
day off and noomi comes in bob neumaya
i miss those days
i really miss those [ __ ] days um all
right legalzoom.com everybody
all right some things like starting a
business or protecting your family with
a will aren't like your other new year's
resolutions you can't afford to blow
them off
instead of less snacking and more
exercise put them at the top of your
list
thank you to the listener who actually
let me know how to read that sentence
legalzoom helps you incorporate or form
an llc with their simple questionnaire
starting at just 99 bucks
over 1 million entrepreneurs have done
it and 90 percent of customers recommend
legalzoom to friends and family you can
also create a will starting at just 69
bucks
or even a living trust quickly and
easily and get peace of mind and
protection no surprise fees no hassles
and no headaches legalzoom's
step-by-step process was created by a
team of experts in law and technology
legalzoom is not a law firm but can
connect you with a third-party attorney
and provide you with self-help self-help
services from wills to business
formations trademarks powers of attorney
and more go to legalzoom.com for even
more savings type burp b-u-r-r into the
referral box to check out don't don't
put things off you need to do go to
legalzoom.com now and use the discount
code burp eur that's legalzoom.com
discount code bur and finally
finally lastly but not leastly
e-voice
you are a business owner but automated
phone systems and secretaries are not in
your budget just yet
and juggling incoming calls yourself
makes it hard to look like a
professional here's something that will
dramatically help you make more money in
2014 it's e-voice everybody whether
you're a business of one or one hundred
e-voice will help you manage all of your
incoming calls with the toll-free number
dial by name directory and call routing
tools your business will sound like a
million bucks which is crucial
can't take a call evoice will transcribe
the voicemail and email it to you never
be caught off guard again and with
e-voice you can try it before you buy it
right now just for my listeners you can
get a 60-day free trial to e-voice go to
evoice.com and enter the promo code bill
bill
for the challenge out there at checkout
take charge of your business and make
more money in 2014 go to evoice.com and
enter bill at checkout for your 60-day
free trial that's evoice.com promo code
bill
i'm really up my up reading out loud
game i don't give a [ __ ] if you guys
still think i stink i'm not as bad as i
used to be how about that all right
where are we right now 54 minutes and we
haven't even started
had so much to talk about this week we
haven't even started doing any of the
reads
um i did get a chance to watch a couple
uh
about 10 minutes of the second period my
flight yesterday was during the bruins
blackhawks game and uh
i love that the blackhawks beat the
ducks and they're still the team to beat
i really love that franchise um
they're they're doing it
the right [ __ ] way they really are
and um
i don't know who's gonna knock them off
but i gotta tell you if you wanna get
into hockey
i would definitely suggest
watching the playoffs when they come up
out west
with
blackhawks the ducks the kings
the sharks at some point are they going
to push through i mean they just really
got a lot of great teams out there they
play great hockey who'd ever thought
that
in hockey going through anaheim los
angeles in san jose would be a brutal
road trip it's [ __ ] unreal
it's a great thing anyways
um enough with the movies uh big bad
bill is sweet william now okay here
comes some criticism for the week i like
this i like having the occasional
criticism you guys can start sending in
your criticisms of the week
uh just put that in the uh the subject
line like this okay bill of all your
comedic and podcast talents of which
there are many look what he's doing
he set me up oh he's patting me on the
head
because of all your yadda yadda your
talents and all that [ __ ] movie reviews
is not one of them
do i do movie reviews i don't think i do
he goes to be to be blunt you suck at
reviewing movies when you say things
like you know the one guy who was in
that other one where they did that thing
you sound like tony soprano talking on a
compromised phone line
and when was the last time
when every movie you saw wasn't great
[Music]
the only moderately intelligent thing i
heard you say regarding movies was last
summer when you went off on the whole
pg-13 zombie movie trend which of course
was spot on it's entirely ridiculous to
have a zombie flick that isn't rated r
at the minimum they should all probably
be nc 17. well you know what's funny sir
mr criticism was i was actually wrong
i already forget the name of the movie
that movie mars volta what the [ __ ] was
it called
brad world war z
how the [ __ ] did i get mars vault with
bars there it is there was the z in
there
i have a learning disability you [ __ ]
and i was wrong about that what was what
actually made world war z great
was the fact that it was pg-13 so then
relying on gore and shock and 3d and all
that crap they couldn't they actually
had to build suspense and that's what's
missing out of a lot of [ __ ] of the
uh
the big time summer movies there you go
how's that critique
how does that grab you were actually
[ __ ] wrong about that world war z is
a great [ __ ] movie
great i loved it two thumbs up two
freckle thumbs right up your [ __ ] ass
all right let's finish this uh critique
here he goes but when talking about
individual movies you might want to
consider not doing
that christ
you might want to consider having some
sort of original criticism instead of
speaking in sound bites
you might want to consider not doing
that
um he goes or maybe get one of your
comedy in quote in quotes friends
to guests review movies for you oh you
don't think my friends are funny you
don't think that i know people
who are funny
is that what you're saying so what do
you do who are you [ __ ] on here with
your little hipster air quotes uh he
then goes on to say i'm sure you have
one or 20 that would desperately be
grateful for the exposure
look at that look at that see that now
he's making fun of the desperation of
being in uh show business this is all
kinds of just lefts and little little
pitter pat rights you know little
flyweight here
working the body
he goes just trying to be helpful
anyways you'll probably continue to do
this but i hope from now on you will
have a little voice in your head telling
you it's a bad idea there's his ego
wanting to help that you know he affects
my reads in the future or whatever the
[ __ ] it is that i'm doing ego that would
be enough for me even if you don't read
this on the podcast p.s belichick and
his cheaters are no different than all
those roid pumping home run record
holders all right sounds like a colts
fan
um
anyways uh sir i don't review movies
i don't review movies and when i watch
them i can't remember who's in them i
can't remember the names of people i
can't it's it's you know what it is it's
part of getting old and you have other
[ __ ] to do with your life
you know i'm sure you still have a
[ __ ] uh orson welles poster on your
wall whoever's the young hottie today
ryan gosling
right i'm sure you have one of those up
on your wall and this is like a big part
of your [ __ ] life but it isn't a big
part of my life it isn't all right i
only have so much time i have too many
[ __ ] hobbies i can't remember that i
can't remember the names of restaurants
all the restaurants that we have out
here i just they're just i just have
nicknames for them i don't know why
you know maybe i talk on a cell phone
too much but uh you know
you know it's funny one of my favorite
movies of all time is no country for old
men that already i can't remember if
i've even said this already no country
for old men i just watched it again last
night and i i always forget
if it's old man or old man i think i
already said that in this podcast didn't
i
did i i don't [ __ ] know um anyways
well whatever sir yeah you will be in my
head every time i say it now but it's
gonna be in a good way knowing that i'm
annoying the [ __ ] out of you
um and in the
future um
if you ever want a comedian to stop
doing something uh one of the best
things you could do
is not let them know that what they're
doing annoys you
because that's one of my favorite things
to do is to annoy the [ __ ] out of people
so uh there you go
my movie reviews will continue and i
will be thinking about you sir every
time i do them
um you might want to think about not
doing that ugh
oh jesus christ
hey guys how about more chivon t-shirts
they're all hilarious
oh jesus come to greece hey bill if you
ever come in
i can't even i don't know what that is
thessaloniki
greece
there will be a house waiting for you
huge fan
oh isn't that nice
isn't that nice well sir i i hope
someday i get to i would love to do
stand-up in greece
go over there make a couple hundred
bucks you know
go out there look at some ruins and some
[ __ ]
greek women i'm up for it
um
all right dude those those chive on
t-shirts are this generations i'm with
stupid
t-shirts jesus christ
i'm [ __ ] believable i think i've seen
every chive on
what does it carry on is that what it
was
relax and and
that's what it is relax and i don't even
know what the [ __ ] they say
i just keep seeing people with them and
i just it just always blows my mind like
how do you still think that's funny
or just a funny t-shirt in general i
just love how it's like the joke that
doesn't leave like somebody reads it and
it's funny
and then they laugh
and then then you're still standing
there with the joke on your t-shirt
you guys remember how they used to end
that show police squad
where they used to make fun of uh when
they would do the free freeze frames
like on chips
when chips used to end somebody would
always make a joke and then they'd start
laughing and then they'd freeze it and
then they'd show some credits and then
they'd have the footage move a little
more and then somebody else would do
something else would make everybody
laugh and then they'd freeze that they
kind of made fun of that except they
weren't freezing the frame and they were
just standing there that's basically
what those t-shirts are
it's the uh police squad ending
version of a t-shirt right jesus that
was a long way to go i need a glass of
water
all right response to college kid
dealing with rumors
hey billy butt [ __ ]
jesus christ
can we be nicer in 2014
he said i'm having some
i have some advice for the kid who is
dealing with the rumor of him getting a
younger girl drunk and [ __ ] her in
the elevator all right so obviously
you're assuming that this dude was
innocent
how can i get out of the abyss of these
sexual the sex crime questions here
about potential sex crimes um
all right here we go i'm a recent
college grad
who had to deal with tons of rumors
being made about me i was in a
fraternity that's a red flag i partied a
lot red flag number two throughout my
college career career he comes from
money
red flag number three
um and [ __ ] you don't think i'm just
some typical frat douche bag you don't
know my life ah you busted me
you busted me
that was awesome
ah [ __ ] he goes i used to deal with the
same thing i would go to introduce
myself to girls and once they found out
who i was they would either walk away or
get that [ __ ] off look on their faces
all right now what did you do what were
you accused of here
he goes this kid needs to stop being a
[ __ ] and just [ __ ] go with it he
should be like yeah i [ __ ] that chick
in the elevator yeah that doesn't sound
like a frat guy here frat guy advice uh
he'd get some respect from dudes at
parties and if he walked around with
confidence and embrace it girls will
eventually come around too all right so
this guy's taking the uh just continue
being a dick
which uh actually it is it is very uh
it is effective i guess from personal
experience
as much girls would want nothing to do
with me
the same amount of girls would actually
come on to me because all the outrageous
things i've done or have been rumored to
have done none of which you're bringing
up
he said he's in college there's tons of
hot easy chicks who want to hook up with
wild guy all right this guy's gross all
right i'm moving on um article on comics
being psychos
uh
billy stray jacket
i was at the wilton theater gig and it
was the best new year's i've ever had
well you know what it was one of the
best i've had too man you guys were a
great crowd so thank you um
he says i hope you come back next year
even if there's an overlap in material
people pay to see the stones touch
trudge through jumping jack flash every
goddamn year yeah but you can't dance to
my jokes
[Laughter]
what's the [ __ ] deal with obama i
can't i can't sing them it's just
no dude you know what it is you think
that you want you don't mind if there's
overlap well i guess you are saying
overlap but you're still saying come
with some new [ __ ] uh believe me i would
love to do the will turn every year
that was such a thrill to work there so
i'm glad you were there anyways um
he says enough ass kick kissing i'm sure
you've seen this article making the
rounds about comics being psychos what
are your thoughts my girlfriend said you
made a comment about it on twitter was
hoping you could elaborate
uh
go [ __ ] yourself and tell neil we love
her um oh yeah yeah there was a study by
scientists
we're trying to figure out i guess why
comedians are funny
and then they just said that because
we're basically we share the same traits
or we are psychos
um i started to read that and um
it's ridiculous
um
to attribute it
to that it's first of all they're making
it's it's just a giant generalization
there are comics who are psychos but
there are also truck drivers who are
psychos there's teachers there's mothers
there's dentists there's lawyers
heads of corporations politicians
they're psychos
exists um
i really don't feel that it
that that article has basically no
credit on
for me anyways as far as like
i'm not saying that comedians aren't
psychos
um
but i mean this sounded like they were
saying literally psychos
i mean we're out of our [ __ ] minds
but i think a lot of people are
um
but my the the reason why i don't buy
into it
it might be on defensive because i am a
comedian i will entertain that but
nobody i know was interviewed for that
article and no comic i know
whose worth of [ __ ] would
would want to take time out of their day
because that's a that's like
at the very least the only people they
got were either struggling
new
or old desperate like comics who just
needed 25 bucks to be part of this study
and then
their comics
there's no [ __ ] way i would ever go
into a lab
and somebody's like asking me questions
there is no
[ __ ] way i could resist
giving misinformation and watching the
guy write it down
and add it into his lab book with
[ __ ] beakers and graduated cylinders
behind him i would have all i could do
to hold a straight face throughout the
entire process so um
look if you want to know why people are
funny it's a gift you're just born with
it the same way
somebody can
a carpenter is born with a gift you just
you're just born with gifts that's it's
it's a gift
it's not like oh maybe if i'm more like
this i'll be funnier you just either can
do it or you can't
and then like any gift if you
work at it
if you appreciate the gift you've been
given and then you try to develop it you
can get better at it
you can actually get funnier if you push
yourself it's weird i didn't think i
thought you were kind of born with your
level of funny but it's it's like any
other talent you just got to keep
working but if you're not born with it
it's like me i can't i mean i can't sing
i'd love to be able to sing it doesn't
stop me from singing on the [ __ ]
podcast but like
you got to be born with that
i could take as many singing lessons as
i wanted to when you could sit there and
try to break down the psychology of a
musician i'm not a musician
as much as i would love to be i still
play drums as a [ __ ] hobby i also
cook a little bit but you wouldn't want
to go to my restaurant there
right so
that's what i think about it i think
it's ridiculous and i thought it was
really funny that some of the tweets i
got were
um
i love this one guy like just the
[ __ ] ego
on just the the average everyday person
because they always talk about how
people in the public eye are egomaniacs
i don't think we're any different than
anybody in the [ __ ] crowd
it's a same level ego some guy sends me
this [ __ ] tweet and he goes this
article proves what i've always thought
about comedians
oh really
your study that you never did with all
the comedians you never hung out with
and this this one [ __ ] article proves
it
i don't know it's more like aren't you
just unhappy with your own life on some
level and it's great to see that they're
saying that these people uh who do this
admirable thing are actually all
psychopaths so it makes you feel better
about whatever your lot in life
i don't [ __ ] know um
whatever that's that's what i feel about
it i might be wrong maybe i'm a psycho
and i can't wrap my head around it all
right imperial japanese hold holdout
dies at 91.
hey wild bill redcock
oh they're so childish yet they always
make me laugh uh you'll like this
article one of several japanese soldiers
who continued to fight the war until the
1970s deep in the jungles of the
philippines recently died at 91. yeah i
talked about a couple of these guys
there was like three of them
who didn't know the war was ended and
you know even when the the the leaflets
of the flyers were dropped
from planes they thought it was uh
allied propaganda
and they just held the company line i
think one of them
one of them the first guy i think was
the 1960s they finally got them late 60s
and then they got two others in like the
early 70s i think one guy went all the
way to 1974 basically the end of the
vietnam war he was still
on some god forsaken island out in the
pacific fighting world war ii
anyways he said it took his former
commanding officer to find him in the
jungle in his jungle hideout and tell
him it was a wrap
and he needed to stop killing filipinos
for him to finally come home
the guy was convicted
guy was convinced seeing all the us
military air traffic heading to vietnam
that the war was still on despite
hundreds of leaflets and newspapers
flown in and dropped to his location uh
the link is below go [ __ ] yourself and
hope to see you in cleveland soon yeah
that's it's a fascinating
fascinating [ __ ] story that that's
what was a major chunk of that man's
life
uh
jesus christ if i ever
for some reason was chosen to give a
speech on stick-to-itiveness that would
probably be the uh the
it would be that guy would be the
lightning rod the crux of the speech
um anyways uh long-distance hiking is
this this is the last one everybody this
is it and that's all there is for this
week long distance hiking
hey bill on january on the january 7th
podcast you went off about getting stuck
in the woods alone and mauled by giant
animals last september me and two
buddies hiked in
hiked a portion of the hundred mile
wilderness
in maine which is the last leg of the
appalachian trail
took four days they went 40 miles in
five mountains
with 35 pound packs on our backs
dude i'm getting scared just [ __ ]
hearing about that i know there's a lot
of people you [ __ ] [ __ ] go out there
go out there with you and a couple of
your [ __ ] buddies when you can't hear
see or anything other than just [ __ ]
nature and you start seeing tracks
of animals that could maul you to death
and it is no [ __ ] joke
um
he said on our fourth and final day in
the woods after getting rained on all
night we encountered a bull moose on the
trail
if you've never seen a moose close up
they're [ __ ] huge
jesus christ dude i thought you were
going to go a little more in depth than
that i was all excited if you've never
seen a moose close up yeah yeah
they're [ __ ] huge
[Laughter]
oh he goes on a little more like a
full-size pickup truck huge at first it
didn't see us which is always dangerous
and then like a scene out of a movie my
friend stepped on a twig and it snapped
under his foot
what happened next was the most sphinx
sphincter that i said tightening
experience
of my life this thing lifted its head up
looks me right in the eye and starts
charging down the trail at us oh my god
all three of us dropped our packs and
ran as fast as we could off the trail
fortunately moose have shitty eyesight
so we were able to lose it you know what
i was actually picturing is i'm just
picturing zadino charis skating at me
and just hoping he can't turn
[Laughter]
fortunately moose have shitty eyesight i
think with those long skinny legs they
can't you know if you do a little barry
sanders move
you know dodge it at the last second
um he said they have shitty eyesight so
we were able to lose it
and he continued on down the trail no
doubt
uh to scare the [ __ ] out of some more
hikers
what we later learned is that september
starts the rut from moose mating season
so not only was this thing pissed
we were in its house it wanted to [ __ ]
us
um
jesus christ you know as scary as that
is i would actually love to do it
just to see if i could uh
if i could hike that far just the
physical test of it
but i would have to go out there with uh
somebody really experienced who had a
[ __ ] firearm cocked and loaded and
pointed in all directions and i'm in the
center of it and then i think i could
actually [ __ ] do it whatever i have
respect every respect for [ __ ] uh the
wilderness and i'm i'm terrified of the
ocean
i i won't go in it
it's [ __ ] nuts all right
if you had a medium-sized alligator and
a pool i wouldn't go in that either why
would i go into the ocean
where all sharks other than the ones in
aquariums exist
i don't [ __ ] do that all right and
anyways
all right that's the podcast for this
week everybody um
yeah that's it i'm really excited about
this super bowl and uh try it this year
try one year not to just watch all the
[ __ ] hype
start the game an hour and a half late
drink a couple millers
and put it on i'm telling you can
actually maybe get for the old guys out
there maybe you can get back to some of
the way it used to be
um
you know
back in the old [ __ ] days all right
that's the podcast for this week um
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk
to you next week and next week i'll be
telling you stories about hawaii and the
pro bowl oh isn't that exciting well it
is to me
you